rappel le ring j'ai 27 ans et myriam
j'ai 29 ans la famille senti belle
pauline j'ai 25 ans je suis confiné seul
dans mon appartement à paris
je fais du télétravail en semaine et en
dehors du travail du coup je fais
beaucoup plus d'activités de l'intérieur
quand je fais du sport à la maison temps
en temps je sors courir d'or j'étais
sorti quatre à cinq fois pour faire les
courses
courir aller dans un centre devant du
sang mais après je trouve que
l'atmosphère d'or est assez particulière
je m'étais fait contrôlé trois fois pour
avoir prédit tubing ça c'est très sens
et on se sent surveillé
j'habite à la base seul mais au vu de la
situation à l'internât de mon frère a
fermé ses portes
donc en habitant confinement ensemble je
ne sors pas vraiment m'arrive parfois de
sortir pour prendre l'air habitait dans
un appartement sans vacances en terrasse
ça peut être dur parfois donc sinon
c'est pour faire des courses en général
les idées avec mon conjoint de vivre le
confinement chez ma mère qui habite une
maison à antony
nous sommes six à partager la maison
donc avec mon frère ma mère et du coup
leurs conjoints respectifs c'est une
colocation familiale qui se passe plutôt
bien
l'après midi chacun fait ses activités
de son côté et on se retrouve assez
régulièrement pour faire du coût des
activités en famille comme regarder un
trou tous ensemble jouent à un jeu de
société ou même partagé je ne veux pas
on fait aussi un petit peu de bissone
dans le jardin quand il fait beau il a
toujours envie de sortir mais on essaie
de le devenir
moi c'est pour faire tous les moteurs de
bacon en fait dès qu'on a besoin il a
besoin
[Musique]
mais de faire les courses et nous on
sent pas du tout du tout du tout pas
pouvoir sortir librement
cela serait frustrant parce que ça
change quand même tout un rythme de vie
une organisation on a une perte de
notion du temps et puis très belle
quatre journées calories l'est et c'est
vrai que du coup on doit réapprendre à
occuper son temps assez différemment on
n'a plus le travail pour rythmer un
petit peu nos vies c'est très dur d'être
confiné surtout quand il ya du soleil
mais on n'a pas trop le choix
il faut rester chez nous restez chez
vous après nous aurons tout le temps
pour rattraper le temps perdu
les trois quatre premiers jours mais
maintenant c'est bien fait on fait du
toboggan
on a fait des gâteaux on a fait plein
d'autres mais on a joué dans le bain
plus longtemps et puis on fait des
nouvelles activités
eh bien ça se regarde et au coude en
famille et puis en fait va on y voit des
points positifs
- je le temps de développer ma patience
dans la cuisine la passion dans le yoga
dans le dessin et puis l' avantage aussi
on est tous dans le même bateau donc
tous au camp fille demandant pas de
jaloux je suis en contact régulièrement
avec ma soeur mes amis on s'appelle on
sur les messages des blagues sur
internet
j'ai fait un skype à skype apéro c'est
important voilà deux de se rencontrer
même si c'est virtuel de savoir comment
les uns et les autres oblige
leur confinement et chaussées vente
essentiel de garder un contact avec
l'extérieur
on a aujourd'hui beaucoup moyens de
communication via les réseaux on a deux
les appels en visio donc ça permet quand
même de garder un lien social avec
l'extérieur qui n'est pas négligeable ya
une collision aussi avec tout le monde
qu'il est paradoxalement manque de lien
social
les gens sont quand même plus où des
plus positifs je vois beaucoup plus de
bienveillance sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment le fait qu'on se retrouve tous
les soirs tous ensemble pour applaudir
le corps médical qui qui s'occupe de
votre antenne ut jour josette très
émouvant entre voisins on applaudit à
20h et puis après on chante une chanson
et le midi à notre voisine qui est
pianiste et on joue tous les midis
certeau du foot ou et tous les voisins
de la rue en fait les frais
[Musique]
son plus proche des autres finalement en
étant confiné
j'espère qu'il y aura un après positif
est-ce qu'on filme en sur l'aspect
humain solidaire environnementale et
j'espère que certaines bonnes habitudes
des restaurants que c'est important
aujourd'hui de tirer profit de la
situation je m'étais acheté une guitare
l'été dernier que je n'ai jamais touché
et du coup là je prends le temps
d'apprendre à jouer
je voulais aussi ré apprendre le
mandarin et du coup maintenant j'aime
beaucoup de temps devant moi pour faire
tout ça
je sais quand même voilà de m'entretenir
me faire plaisir et préparait pour le
retour d'une vie normale
[Musique]